THERE THEY ARE AND HERE WE
GO.
RIGHT, THIS WEEK IT WAS ALL
PUBLIC HEARING.
[INAUDIBLE]
NOTHING NEW, WHAT A FARCE.
LET'S START BY ENJOYING FOR A
MOMENT THE LAUGHABLE HYPOCRISY
OF THE DEMOCRATS LAST MAJOR
IMPEACHMENT SCANDAL.
APPARENTLY IT'S ABOUT BRIBERY
NOW.
NANCY PELOSI SAID SO AND THEY
ALL STAND IN LINE.
>> TO WITHHOLD MILITARY
ASSISTANCE IN RETURN FOR A
PUBLIC STATEMENT OF THE FAKE
INVESTIGATION INTO THE
ELECTION, THAT'S BRIBERY.
>> BRIBERY, BRIBERY, BRIBERY,
BRIBERY.
>> BRIBERY?
ARE THEY KIDDING, IN THE SWAMP
BRIBERY IS THERE IS THIS
MODEL.
IT'S MONEY IN EXCHANGE FOR A
POLITICAL FAVOR.
IT'S A BRIBE.
LET'S PICK SOME RANDOM
EXAMPLES, OVERLOOK, ADAM
SCHIFF, HE TOOK OVER $350,000
IN BRIBES FROM THE DEFENSE
SECRETARY.
SURPRISE SURPRISE AND PUSHED
MILITARY ACTION OVERSEAS.
HE TOOK OVER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM AT&T.
WHEN IT WAS REPORTED THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP WANTED TO
BLOCK THE MERGER, GUESS WHO
PIPED UP ON AT&T BEHALF.
SHIFTY SHIFT.
HOW ABOUT JERRY NADLER.
HE TOOK OVER $80000 IN
EXCHANGE VOTED AGAINST CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND VOUCHER PROGRAMS
AND DONE THE QUEEN OF BRIBERY,
NANCY PELOSI SHE BOASTS ABOUT
HER FUND RAISING, RAISING
MONEY IS THE WAY SHE CLINGS TO
POWER.
HER OFFICE PROBABLY TOLD THE
TIMES THIS YEAR THAT SHE HAS
RAISED OVER $700 MILLION SINCE
2002.
DOES ANYONE THINK THAT MONEY
IS ANYTHING OTHER THAN BRIBES
QUESTION MARKET WORKED FOR A
VISA, THEY GAVE OVER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO DEMOCRATS
ON TOP OF THE FACT THAT NANCY
HERSELF HAD PREFERENTIAL STOCK
IN THE COMPANY.
THOSE BRIBES HELP NANCY PELOSI
CUT OFF LEGISLATION THAT WOULD
PROMOTE THEIR VISAS.
SHE HAS TAKEN MONEY FROM
LOBBYISTS REPRESENTING SHADY
COMPANIES IN THE UKRAINE.
BRIBERY BY NAME IS NANCY.
SO, WHAT HAVE THE DEMOCRATS
ACHIEVED WITH THEIR
IMPEACHMENT REBRANDING AND
PUBLIC PARADE OF DISGRUNTLED
BUREAUCRATS.
IT WASN'T DAMAGING TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP AS THEY PLAN.
IT ACTUALLY HURT THE RULING
CLASS AND THE ESTABLISHMENT
WHO HAVE DECLARED WAR ON
PRESIDENT TRUMP BECAUSE IT
EXPOSED FOR ALL TO SEE THEIR
SNOOTY ARROGANCE AND CONTEMPT
AT DEMOCRACY.
THIS WAS THE CURRENT UKRAINE
AMBASSADOR.
>> I AM NOT HERE TO TAKE ONE
SIDE OR THE OTHER.
>> THE ESTABLISHMENT SIDE, THE
BUREAUCRACY SIDE, THE RULING
CLASS SIDE, THIS IS NOT ABOUT
REPUBLICAN VERSUS DEMOCRAT,
THAT'S WHY THEY ARE UPSET.
>> I ENCOUNTERED AN IRREGULAR
CHANNEL OF POLICYMAKING.
>> EXTREMELY REGULAR.
>> THERE ARE IRREGULAR
CHANNEL.
>> HIGHLY IRREGULAR.
>> THAT'S BUREAUCRAT FOR
DEPLORABLE.
, HE IS STRIKING BACK, HE
WANTS A POLICY THAT STANDS UP
FOR AMERICA IN THE WORLD BUT
THEY WANT TO KEEP IT STANDING
UP FOR THE WORLD IN AMERICA.
TRUMP THANKS PROMISES MADE
SHOULD BE KEPT, THEY WANT TO
IGNORE THEM AS IF THEY NEVER
HAPPEN.
TRUMP WANTS TO GOVERN, THEY
CHOOSE TO OBSTRUCTION.
HE WANTS REELECTION, THEY
WON'T TAKE THE RISK.
BUT DOES THE RULING CLASS EVEN
UNDERSTAND HOW MUCH DAMAGE
IT'S DOING TO AMERICA'S FABRIC
WITH THEIR RECKLESS DEMENTED
DRIVE TO IMPEACH HIM BECAUSE
THEY'RE WORRIED HE WILL WIN AN
ACTUAL ELECTION?
THEY'VE DESTROYED TRUST LONG
AGO IN THE FBI, THE CIA, THE
WHOLE SYSTEM.
THEY'VE MADE SURE FUTURE
PRESIDENTS CAN'T HAVE
CONFIDENTIAL RELATIONS WITH
FOREIGN LEADERS.
THEY'VE DISTRACTED AND DIVIDED
THE COUNTRY AND GUARANTEED THE
NEXT DEMOCRAT PRESIDENT WILL
ALSO BE IMPEACH.
I HEAR PEOPLE SAY ALL THE TIME
HOW CAN YOU SUPPORT TRUMP.
LOOK AT HIS BEHAVIOR AND HIS
TWEETS.
I SAY LOOK AT HIS RESULTS.
WORKING AMERICANS GETTING A
PAY RAISE AFTER A DECADE OF
STAGNATION, ENGINEERED BY THE
SAME ESTABLISHMENT GENIUSES
BLOCKING HIS EVERY MOVE.
THE NUMBER ONE ENEMY, CHINA,
FINALLY CONFRONTED AFTER
SUCKING UP TO THE SAME
GENIUSES NOW PLOTTING TO KICK
TRUMP OUT AND THEN LOOK AT HIS
ENEMIES, HOWEVER BAD THEY
THINK HE MAY BE, HIS ENEMIES
ARE WORSE.
THEY ARE COMPLETELY
INSUFFERABLE, POMPOUS, SELF
RIGHTEOUS, THEY ARE
SUPERFICIAL, ALWAYS PUTTING
STYLE OVER SUBSTANCE, AND THEY
ARE OBLIVIOUS TO THE DAMAGE
THEY THEMSELVES DID TO THE
COUNTRY WITH THEIR ELITIST
POLICY AGENDA AND THE DAMAGE
THEY ARE DOING NOW WITH THEIR
DIVISIVE IMPEACHMENT AGENDA.
THE DEMOCRATS TALK ABOUT
JUSTICE.
I'LL TELL YOU WHAT JUSTICE
LOOKS LIKE.
THESE CRAZED PARTISAN
DEMOCRATS SENT TO THE
POLITICAL WILDERNESS
WILDERNESS, THE WHITE HOUSE,
CONGRESS, STATE AND LOCAL